- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large brained. Lng the
master of fire, tools, and language but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Mark] I first got interested in lice
many years ago when my now 25-year-old son
was in elementary school and he came home
with one of those fliers saying that one
of the kids in his class had genital lice
and what sorts of things parents should be
on the lookout for. Also included was a
flier with a bunch of what I refer to as
fun facts about human lice that I didn't
know about. These includes the facts that
our lice only parasitize humans. They
don't live on cats or dogs or your other
pets. You don't have to worry about
picking it up from them or transferring
them to your pets. In other words, this
means they're obligate parasite of humans.
They can only live on human hosts.
Secondly, they can't survive more than
about 24 hours away from the human body.
That means they can't take up residence in
your bedding or your clothing or except,
you know, be infected from that source. I
thought, well if this is true, then what
that means is that the spread of lice
around the world must have been
accomplished by the spread of humans
around the world. And since human
migrations is something that I'm
interested in, that maybe by studying
lice, we can learn something more about
human migrations. Then, a few years later
when I actually had time to start looking
into this in more detail, I found out that
was actually potentially even more
interesting because us humans, we like to
think about what and look into what makes
us special, what makes us different from
other creatures. One of the things that
makes us unique, as far as I know, in the
animal world, is that we were the only
species parasitized by three different
types of lice. Lice are ubiquitous. All
mammals have lice, birds have lice, fish
have lice, but we alone have three
different types of lice. Two of these,
that I'll talk about, start out, and then
mention the third one later, are the head
louse, pediculus capitis, and the body
louse, pediculus humanus, or sometimes
also classified as a subspecies of
pediculus capitis. As you can see,
morphologically, they look quite similar.
What actually differentiates them is their
ecology. The head louse, as the name
suggests, lives and feeds exclusively on
the human scalp. Body louse feeds on the
body but actually lives in the clothing
and lays its eggs in clothing. Now you ask
yourself, how would this difference come
about? Why would we have two different
kinds of lice that do these two different
things? The answer that seems to make the
most sense is that this ecological
difference between head and body louse
probably arose when clothing became
important in human evolution. Then, it
became available as a new niche, a new
ecological niche that lice can move into
and start exploiting and start adapting
to. It evolved to become body lice. If
that's true, if you buy that, what we can
do is use a molecular clock approach and
we can date the origin of body lice, the
divergence between head and body lice. By
inference, that tells us when clothing
became important in human evolution. Will
we need to do the molecular clock? Well
the molecular clock is a long-standing
idea in evolutionary genetics and it goes
back to the idea that the rate of
evolution, the rate of change of DNA
sequences is approximately constant over
time. This idea is supported by a good
deal of observation. You take pairs of
species where you have some idea when they
diverge from fossil to bio-geographic
evidence, you measure the amount of DNA
divergence between them and you plot that,
and you see very strong and astonishingly
close correlation between how much
divergence there is in DNA sequences and
how long ago those two species last shared
a common ancestor. It's also supported by
theory, but I'll skip over the gory
details of that. So what do we need in
order to use a molecular clock approach?
Well, we need a calibration point. We need
to know how fast the clock is ticking. We
need to know what is the rate of change in
our DNA sequences. What we did, in order
to do this, is we assume that when
chimpanzees and humans diverged, chimps
being the the closest living relative of
humans, so did their lice.
The idea that when hosts diverge, their
parasites also diverge is this
co-evolution between host and parasites. A
long standing observation biology. There
are certainly many exceptions to it, but
by and large, it is the rule. When host
speciate so do their spare parasites. We
therefore, can get an idea of how fast the
clock is ticking, if we can take
chimpanzee lice, compare them to human
lice, measure their DNA differentiation,
and we assume that differentiation
occurred about six million years ago.
Well, that then gives us our calibration,
that tells us how fast the clock is
ticking. In addition to do this work, we
need our lice samples. We got head lice
and body lice from all different sources
around the world. Not everyone was pleased
to hear from us and sometimes, we got
rather indignant responses about how dare
we suggest they might have lice at their
facility. But nonetheless, we got a good
worldwide sample of lice. We also got
chimpanzee lice, pediculus schaeffi from
the chimp sanctuary in Uganda. What is
also very important, since we have no clue
as to what these things are actually
supposed to look like, we had a local
expert examine them and confirm that the
identifications are indeed correct. Then,
what we did was we obtained DNA sequences
from these lice. We obtained two
mitochondrial DNA gene sequences which
gave the same results when analyzed
separately so we combine them, analyze
them together. Also, just to make sure
that there wasn't something strange about
the mitochondrial DNA, we obtained and
analyzed sequences of two nuclear genes.
Then, we did a couple of sanity checks to
make sure that the results we were
getting, they're corresponding to what we
might expect. One who things we looked at
was a genetic diversity in the African
lice versus the non-African lice. What you
can see is that all of these genes have
different amounts of diversity which is
what we always observe because the amount
of diversity in a gene is a reflection of
the functional constraints on that gene,
but what we also see is that for each
gene, there's more diversity in the
African lice than in the non-African lice.
Greater diversity implies that's where the
source is, that's where the origin is
because you had the most time, you
accumulate the most diversity. That's good
because what this indicates is that
greater diversity in African lice implies
an African origin of human lice. And since
that's where we think humans arose, that's
a good sanity check. The other check we
did on this is to compare the head lice
and the body lice. Again, you can see for
each of these three genes more diversity
in the head lice than in the body lice.
That fits with the scenario I told you
about that body lice are more recent in
origin than the head lice. They've had
less time to accumulate diversity. Now we
can do a phylogenetic analysis, putting
together all of these lice sequences using
the chimpanzee louse as an outgroup. The
Hs are the head lice, the Bs are the body
lice, the numbers in parenthesis are the
numbers of individual lice that had that
particular sequence. When we apply the
molecular clock approach, we see that the
clay here that contains all of the body
lice sequences as well as some of the head
lice sequences has an age of about 70,000
years ago, give or take, a few tens of
thousands of years. What we can also see
in this tree is that there is a particular
clay there which contains all of the body
lice as well as some of the head lice
sequences which has lots and lots of
little short branches. And that's a
signature of a population expansion. But
we also see in this analysis is evidence
for a population expansion occurring in
lice around this time. The conclusion we
came up with, from the study, is that body
lice arose about 70,000 years ago, which
then implies that that's when clothing
became important in human evolution,
provided the niche for the body lice to
start diverging. Now, how does this
compare to archaeological evidence
concerning the origin of clothing? Well,
clothing itself doesn't fossilize, so what
we have to do is rely on indirect
evidence.
If we look at the indirect evidence, stone
tools and bone tools, that would be
unequivocally associated with clothing;
things, like needles for example. Those
are on the order of about 40,000 years old
at the most. Now, there are certainly
other tools around like scrapers that
potentially could have been used to
prepare hides for clothing by scraping
them off, but they also could be used for
other purposes. We don't really know for
sure what all they were being used for.
The overall conclusion is if we look at
the archaeological evidence, it does not
contradict a fairly recent origin of
clothing, only about on the order of
70,000 years ago or so. To summarize the
results of this study, we see that body
lice originated from head lice, again
70,000 years ago or so. We see that
there's also population expansion that
occurred in lice at right around this
time. While this is all very speculative,
what is very tempting to try to relate
this to is the expansion of modern humans
out of Africa which is been dating
directly in DNA evidence in humans to be
between 50 and 100 thousand years ago.
Both suggest that perhaps is when humans
expanded out of Africa, began growing in
size, developed clothing and that this
clothing became available as a niche for
the origin of the body lice. What about
Neanderthals? Whenever you work with
modern humans, sooner or later, someone
will ask you, “Well what about
Neanderthals?” What does this tell us
about Neanderthals and other archaic
humans? Did they have clothing? Well, this
is what we think are the evolutionary
relationships of modern humans and
neanderthals. They shared a common
ancestor 600,000 years ago, give or take a
few tens of thousands of years. Clothing,
if we believe the lice results, originated
sometime here around the dispersion of
modern humans out of Africa. This would
suggest one of two possibilities for
Neanderthals. Either they did not have
clothing, or if they did have clothing
they invented it independently of modern
humans.
In other words, they did not inherit
clothing from a common ancestor of
Neanderthals and modern humans. Now,
there's nothing in what we can infer from
the cognitive abilities of Neanderthals,
based on the archaeological record and so
forth, that would suggest that they were
just too stupid to come up with the idea
of clothing, right? Certainly, quite
feasible, they would have come up with the
idea of clothing on their own, invented it
independently from modern humans. It
certainly is the case that if you look at
reconstruction of Neanderthals, they're
almost always shown in having clothing.
Something like this. There's another
potential view about what Neanderthals
were like. Maybe, they were more like
this. Now, this is a pretty terrible
reconstruction of a Neanderthal from most
perspectives, but I show it here because
it shows neanderthals as having body hair,
as having retained their body hair. That
brings up the question, “Well when did we
actually lose body hair during our
evolutionary history?” We have no clue
about that from fossil evidence, and
modern genetics so far has not been able
to come up with that answer. When did we
lose body hair? If we lost body hair
recently maybe Neanderthals still had body
hair. Maybe then, therefore, when they
moved out of Africa into the colder
climates, they didn't need clothing
because they already their body hair.
There's lots of other mammals that moved
out of Africa at the same time. They
didn't invent clothing. They got along
perfectly well without. That brings up the
question, when did we lose our body hair?
A potential answer from that comes from
the third type of lice that we have.
That's this lovely creature here. This is
a public louse. Pubic lice, as the name
suggests, they live and feed exclusively
in the pubic region. As I've already told
you, the head lice live and feed
exclusively on the scalp. Now, you ask
yourself, how would this difference come
about between these two different types of
lice. The answer that seems to make sense
is that at one time we had body hair, we
had hair all over us, we had one type of
lice then we lost body hair so that we
only have hair in the pubic region and in
the head region. Now, we have a barrier
that the lice can't cross. We have
geographic isolation, we get classic
allopatric speciation, and now we have our
two types of lice.
Well, again, if you buy that, then we can
use the molecular clock approach and ask,
“When did the difference between public
and head lice occur?” and date that
divergence. That might tell us something
about when humans, then lost their body
hair. Now, that all sounds very nice and
neat, however, it's not quite that simple.
Life is never that simple. Here's the view
of lice evolution that I just told you
about. Going back as far as the gorilla
lineage. Gorilla lineage branched off
before the chimpanzee and the human
lineages. If we start with the gorilla
lineage, we have a common ancestor,
gorillas, chimps, and humans. The gorilla
lineage branches off that leads to the
evolution of gorilla louse. Chimp lineage
branches off, that leads to the
differentiation of chimp lice and the
origin of all human lice. We then have
loss of body hair, that leads to the
origin of the pubic louse and finally, we
have clothing and that leads to the origin
of the body louse separate from the head
louse. That looks all very reasonable,
however, the complication is that the
taxonomy, classical taxonomy, of lice does
not agree with this. The classical
taxonomy looks at things this way. Body
louse, in the genus pediculus as I told
you, as is the head louse, as is the
chimpanzee louse, but the pubic louse is
put into a different genus by the
taxonomists, the genus phthirus. That is
the same genus as the gorilla louse. I
will refrain from any speculation as to
how humans might have gotten pubic lice
from gorillas, but one possibility is that
the taxonomy based on morphology is wrong.
There are many examples we know where
taxonomy based on morphology differs from
that based on the DNA.
Clearly, what we need is DNA evidence to
see what's going on here and we also need
DNA from gorilla lice to see what's going
on here. David Reed's group at Florida did
just that and found out that lo and
behold, the taxonomy is recorded by the
DNA. You get the same picture from the
DNA. When did this divergence between
human public lice and gorilla lice occur?
About 3.3 million years ago. If you
believe that this colonization, this
transfer, from gorillas to humans would
have occurred only after humans would have
lost their body hair, which I think is
probably the most reasonable scenario,
then that would suggest that body hair
loss occurred relatively early on in human
evolution, not too long after the
divergence from the chimp lineage which
fits with some other ideas that people
have had about loss of body hair. It would
appear that our ancestors do have some
explaining to do with this. To conclude,
genetic analyses of head and body lice do
indicate that clothing became important
somewhere around 70,000 years ago, seems
to coincide with the expansion of modern
humans out of Africa, maybe had something
to do with that expansion. Genetic
analyses of pubic lice suggest our
ancestors had lost their body hair by
roughly 3, 3.3 million years ago, not so
long after the divergence from
chimpanzees, so it was relatively early
on. On with the acknowledgments, I
especially want to single out Ralf
Kittler, Manfred Kayser, the two people in
my group who did the work we've done on
lice, and all these other people for
contributing samples not necessarily their
own lice samples of course. And the Max
Planck Society for funding all of our
work. Thank you for your attention.
♪ [music] ♪